pendant débat tout de suite avec nos
invités bruno m'égare ban vous êtes
chefs de service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière et jean-pierre scarfone
vous êtes restaurateur et membre de
l'association de lys la vie bonsoir à
vous deux
d'abord c'est un point sur la situation
générale est ce qu'on a entendu la
situation dans les alpes maritimes avec
la circulation des variants très
inquiétant circulation des variants un
peu sur tout le territoire
et puis on a on observe aussi que les
indicateurs de l'épidémie sont plutôt
encourageants quand même fait derniers
jours que faut-il penser de ce paradoxe
bruno mais gardanne
alors effectivement l'épidémie semble
légèrement marqué le pas avec un air 0
désormais à 09 c'est à dire plutôt une
tendance à la régression sur l'ensemble
du territoire et une incidence des
nouveaux cas de contamination en baisse
néanmoins la situation est extrêmement
fragile pour plusieurs raisons tout
d'abord cette amélioration semble se
ralentir
effectivement la baisse de l'épidémie
semble se réduire alors pour différentes
raisons peut-être est-ce un un effet de
l'augmentation de la prévalence des
variants qui est effectivement menaçante
avec aujourd'hui environ 36% de souche
britannique sur le territoire il y a
aussi la difficulté dans laquelle se
trouvent les hôpitaux puisque quand même
la pression
tant sur les réanimations 500 de
saturation de nos lits par les patients
qui ont la cote vide sans compter
évidemment l'afflux des patientes qui
n'ont pas la coved également et le tout
sur un déficit chronique en lits de
réanimation
donc tout ça fait effectivement une
situation extrêmement fragile certes
nous sommes sur un plateau le plateau
temps légèrement abaissé donc il faut
quand même bien sûr garder espoir mais
malheureusement la situation est
extrêmement fragile et il peut y avoir
une envolée à tout moment à cause de ces
variants évidemment et surtout si bien
sûr à l'occasion des vacances un
brassage se faisait dans la population
et l'absence de respect des mesures
barrières permettrait bien sûr de
favoriser la reprise épidémies et
vacances a en ce moment tout cela
n'augure rien de bon jean piat scarfone
dans votre ville
a nice on l'a appris aujourd'hui 700 cas
positifs pour 100000 habitants à nice et
trois fois la moyenne nationale
c'est sûr que c'est assez compliqué
genlis après je d'être médecin
aujourd'hui de faire des réflexions mais
c'est vrai que au jour d'aujourd'hui
restaurants sont fermés
un départ sont fermés et on voit quand
même et l'évolution du coc vite sur la
ville de nice qui évolue donc c'est sûr
que va pas réouvrir les restaurants ça
ne changera pas et au contraire je pense
que à ce jour
comme a dit le ministre c'est compliqué
la situation sur la côte d'azur
sur les alpes maritimes mais c'est vrai
que on a bien vu que l'envolée malgré la
restaurer des restaurants fermés malgré
les pas refermé malgré le cinéma fermé
malgré le sport malgré tout ça ça
continue quand même évolué je pense que
la côte azur vient tourisme importante
l'otan tuent le le climat général des
alpes-maritimes et c'est vrai que en
laissant venir les gens et autant
frontaliers les italiens etc
c'est sûr que
on est un peu tous ces cas là se
multiplient et qu'on brasse des
personnes qui sont pas forcément des
alpes maritimes c'est vrai bruno mais
gardanne dans les alpes maritimes
on le voit bien vu les chiffres le
chiffre que je viens de citer le
couvre-feu avancer les mesures de
restriction pour l'instant ne savent pas
grand chose face aux variants on le voit
qu'il continue de progresser
je vais aussi commenté les chiffres par
exemple taux d'incidence le plus haut de
france dans les alpes maritimes avec 7
587 personnes infectées sur une semaine
pour 100000 habitants invariants anglais
qui représente 50 % des nouveaux cas
dans le département
tout cela est plutôt inquiétant alors
vous avez raison effectivement la
situation dans les alpes maritimes et
notamment dans l'agglomération de neil
de nice est la plus sérieuse sur le
territoire il faut savoir qu'à nice il y
a vingt fois le taux d'incidence du
finistère trois fois celle de la région
ile de france et deux fois celle de la
moselle où on s'était tous inquiétés la
semaine passée alors qu'il y avait déjà
depuis plus d'un mois une situation
extrêmement critique à nice alors
effectivement on peut pas dire que le
couvre-feu n'a pas d'effet parce qu'en
fait malgré tout il contient l'épidémie
et s'il n'y avait pas eu de couvre-feu
la situation était encore pire c'est à
dire probablement analogue à ce qui
s'est passé au royaume uni mais c'est
vrai que le couvre-feu ne semble pas
suffisant parce que partout ailleurs
l'épidémie régresse sauf dans les
alpes-maritimes où l'épidémie continue à
progresser alors évidemment il ya
beaucoup de facteurs
donc les l'arrivée de vacanciers le
maintien de l'aéroport probablement avec
un brassage de populations probablement
on a on a entendu parler de personnes
qui allaient à monaco ou en italie
dans les restaurants et les bars et
malheureusement ne prenait pas de
précautions donc tout ça fait
qu'effectivement la situation est un
petit peu plus difficile alors
il est très probable que le ministre
prenne des décisions de restrictions
supplémentaires alors je ne sais pas si
ça sera un confinement très strict mais
en tout cas probablement des mesures
supplémentaires en tout cas il faut
savoir que les alpes-maritimes sera le
laboratoire de ce qui va se passer dans
15 jours en france car les variants sont
amenés à augmenter contre ce phénomène
on ne pourra rien quelles que soient les
mesures y compris le confinement strict
le la prévalence des variants va
augmenter jusqu'à remplacer totalement
la souche actuellement circulantes par
contre ce qu'il faudrait pas c'est que à
partir d'une certaine prévalence et on
estime qu'à partir de 50 à 60% de
prévalence de la sauce anglaise et ça
semble être désormais le cas à nice il
puisse y avoir une reprise épidémique
il le test est là c'est pourquoi le
président de la république s'est donné
huit à dix jours supplémentaires pour
observer si la pente de commencer à
faiblir et à ce moment là évidemment
ceci serait annonciateur d'une reprise
épidémique vers la mi mars et donc des
mesures de restriction serait prise sur
l'ensemble du territoire
ça veut dire que jean-pierre scarfone et
tous les restaurateurs qui sont dans sa
situation ont très peu finalement
d'espoir de voir de dori donc de rouvrir
ses gardes à pardon donc effectivement
malheureusement malheureusement je crois
qu'il n'y a aucun espoir d'ouverture des
restaurants et des bars avant très
probablement la fin mars
par contre si tous les indicateurs
étaient à la baisse et la régression de
l'épidémie se confirme et sur les quinze
premiers jours de mars
il se pourrait à ce moment là dans la
seconde partie de mars qu'il puisse y
avoir une ouverture pour commencer d'un
certain nombre de lieux culturels
puis progressivement effectivement avec
des protocoles extrêmement strictes
sanitaires les restaurants mais les bars
malheureusement très probablement ça ne
sera pas le cas avant
bah oui jean-pierre scarfone ses délais
ce qu'elle qu'est-ce qu'ils évoquent à
votre niveau
c'est trop tard c'est trop tard c'est
pas le loup c'est au jour d'aujourd'hui
en puis les choses au jour le jour on en
a pas deux on n'arrive pas à se projeter
c'est vrai que quand on nous dit en ré
ouvre le début avril ont ré ou mars en
juin ou en juillet c'est vrai que
malheureusement je pense que
l'observation global de l'es15 terre de
la france oblige à prendre les décisions
mais c'est vrai que on n'arrive pas à se
projeter
je suis restaurateur beaucoup et c'est
vrai que en sauront se dire quoi quel
intérêt aujourd'hui de se dire oh marie
ouvrir en mars
on m'a ri au grain en avril et que quoi
sur nice aujourd'hui l'explosion
l'explosion cas de dire l'explosion de
deux nombres de cas positifs et de ce
variant qui touche 50 % de ces cas
positif c'est vrai que pour nous cette
culture on sent les gens nous on n'ouvre
on peut emporter et à livrer le soir
c'est vrai qu'on ressent aussi les
personnes autour la difficulté la
solitude et l'incompréhension global
dont certains pans de niçois mais
certains français en général plus dire
mais on n'arrive plus à voir défi social
c'est sûr que à choisir la vie sociale
ou surchargés la réanimation et les
hôpitaux je l'entends je comprends et
c'est normal on repas non plus prendre
des risques inconsidérés
mais c'est vrai qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui
notre situation à nous je pense y aura
plus de gens qui vont être des causes
collatéral de duke duke aux vip 19 que
malheureusement des malades qui ont été
atteints c'est vrai que les dommages
collatéraux du côté de 10,9 renault
mégane aussi il faut faut les prendre en
considération votre avis sur cette
proposition des sénateurs qui demande
soixante cinq sénateurs qui ont adressé
une lettre à emmanuel macron ils
demandent la réouverture des restaurants
à midi avec des mesures sanitaires
adéquates et la vente à emporter après
18 heures pour les personnes munies
d'une attestation escaut ça peut faire
exception ça peut fonctionner même dans
le stade actuel de l'épidémie pour aider
les restaurateurs alors alors
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec avec
vous et avec notre ami restaurateur
effectivement malheureusement cette
crise et les mesures de restriction qui
sont nécessaires vont avoir des dégâts
collatéraux
moi je n'ai pas été évidemment partisans
de d'un confinement très strictes
préventif je crois que le président a
pris la bonne décision car aujourd'hui
nous avons des indicateurs qui
permettent en permanence de suivre la
situation et de prendre les mesures
restrictives qui s'imposent
une quinzaine de jours avant la reprise
épidémique alors par contre je ne crois
pas que cette proposition soit
d'actualité aujourd'hui
à mon avis jusqu'à la mi mars nous
sommes dans l'inconnu de l'effet de
l'énergie ans massive des variants donc
tant qu'on n'a pas passé le seuil de 50
à 70% de varien à l'échelle nationale on
ne sait pas encore si oui ou non il va
ya voir reprises épidémique et donc je
crois qu'il n'est pas du tout le moment
d'ouvrir quoi que ce soit voire même
malheureusement il se peut que des
mesures de restriction supplémentaire se
rajoute à linverse si nous passons ce
cap de l'abîmé de la mi mars
sans reprise épidémique et que
l'épidémie continue
bon an mal an de régresser évidemment ça
ne sera pas un rythme très important car
les restrictions restent limitées et
bien là peut-être effectivement après la
mi mars
il se pourrait que l'on puisse envisager
une réouverture de certaines activités
sociales probablement en commençant par
celles qui sont le moins à risque comme
les musées les cinémas et les théâtres
et puis plus progressivement les
restaurants avec les ouvertures à midi
puis le repas à emporter le soir
n'oublions pas que l'une des raisons qui
a fait mettre en place le le le
confinement en octobre novembre
c'est est la poursuite de
décontamination avec les personnes qui
se regroupent et dans les queues et qui
ont profité d'ailleurs pour quelques
moments sauce de d'interactions sociales
je le comprends mais les les repas à
emporter et est devenue l'occasion de
ces rencontres
amical et malheureusement aussi
l'occasion de diffuser le virus mais
jean-pierre scarfone l'ouverture
aujourd'hui à neige mais en dix jours
d'ouverture le midi ça fait comme nos
voisins italiens la cure qui ont ouvert
les restaurants et dix jours après
entourent fermer si je pense que c'est
un drame qui s'est passé chez eux vous
ré ouvrez vous êtes heureux vous
refaites votre stock 10 jours après vous
refermez vaut mieux être sûr je pense
que le virus soit plus ou moins contenue
et qu'on nous voulons qu'on puisse
rouvrir progressivement avec bien sûr
comme on avait fait au départ des
restrictions sanitaires drastiques au
niveau des restaurants et et était
l'autre les budgets que c'est bien mais
c'est vrai que on est en montre toujours
du doigt les établissements restaurants
les bars c'est vrai que à ce moment là -
convivialité le masque mais cela passe
pour manger mais sur les sur les
analyses qu'on fait tous ces grands
chercheurs
c'est vrai que quand vous demandez sur
100 personnes pour une conduite à
l'époque n'était pas confinée ce que
vous avez fait dans la journée c'est sûr
que vous êtes à déport un café où manger
au restaurant ou faire du sport
si tous les points ce relais c'est sûr
que vous dites que le coc vide il dans
les restaurants dans les bars et dans
les salles de sport ou autre
le moment empreint principale où vous
pouvez l'attraper c'est vrai que quand
vous allez dans les parts des grandes
surfaces dans les temps dans d'autres
supermarchés vous tendez des galeries
marchandes et à autant de monde autant
de gens qui se collent autant de gens
qui restent pas des mesures de sécurité
parce que justement vous finissez le
coeur vous avez plutôt fait courser pour
retrouver dans des grandes surfaces et
écrasés les uns sur les autres pour
faire des courses pour rentrer
normalement enfants oui moi je suis dit
je comprends et je suis comme le docteur
je suis d'accord qu'on pourrait ouvrir
quand on est sûr que quand on peut être
serein sur la suite des événements si
pour ré ouvrir et refermer une semaine
après sa chanson sera la paire des
restaurateurs qui l'a perdu
de tous ces petits commerces qui vont au
bout d'un moment j'ai claqué souvient
bruno bécard manne pour terminer votre
avis sur l'impact justement de la
réouverture des restaurants sur le
nombre de contaminations
bah écoutez d'abord je voulais saluer la
position effectivement de notre
interlocuteur restaurateur il a tout à
fait raison je crois qu'il faut être
prudent
malheureusement ce virus a pour mode
principal de contamination la voie
aérienne et notamment les postillons
donc effectivement la situation la
circonstance principale pendant laquelle
on peut se contaminer c'est lorsqu'on
est assis face à face pendant une
certaine période de temps et que l'on se
parle sans mettre de masques donc
typiquement c'est lorsque l'on mange en
société et donc là malheureusement
effectivement il y à un risque de
contamination important c'est pourquoi
effectivement il faut être très prudent
sur la réouverture des restaurants et
l'ensemble des études comme le
démontrent formellement que le fait de
fréquenter les restaurants s'associa
sur-risque de malheureusement d'être
contaminé par le le le kobe 19
c'est pourquoi à nouveau c'est une
occasion de rappeler l'importance de la
vaccination car c'est vraiment le seul
moyen qui va nous permettre de sortir de
cette contamination de cette endémie
avec ce virus anti sociale une fois
protégé évidemment toutes les activités
sociales habituelles pourront reprendre
en sécurité alors là aussi il ya
beaucoup à dire sur la vaccination on
n'a pas le temps parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de retard c'est dans cette campagne de
vaccination merci à vous bruno m'égare
ban êtes chefs de service réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière merci à vous jean
pierre scarfone restaurateurs membres de
l'association nice la vision